on va continuer de parler de la
situation épidémique avec jean-paul à
mon médecin généraliste et président
d'honneur de la fédération des médecins
de france
bonjour jean paul hamon merci d'être
avec nous ce matin sur rtl france alors
on vient de le dire un tout à l'heure le
nombre de personnes contaminées par le
cos vie 19 ne cesse d'augmenter
cependant et le nombre
d'hospitalisations à reste stable
la question est ce qu'il faut
s'inquiéter non il faut pas il faut quoi
s'inquiéter
vous savez quand on annonce qu'un décès
sur sur la france entière
quand on avance qu'elle décès sur la
france entière il faut absolument pas
s'inquiéter parce que ça veut dire que
on a testé on a testé infiniment plus
que contestait il y à il ya quelques
mois
il ya quelques mois on faisait cinq
mille tests summit est par semaine on
est en droit d'en faire plus de 100000
par semaine donc c'est normal contre
davantage de cas les chiffres qui pose
surveillait ce sont les nombre
d'hospitalisations qui n'augmentent pas
ou très peu et le nom de personnes en
réanimation qui n'augmentent pas ou très
peu
ceci étant il faut il faut quand même
responsabiliser la population
c'est vrai qu'il faut porter et faire
porter un effort sur tous les lieux
fermés où le risque de contamination et
est important et c'est là qu'il faut
faire respecter des mesures barrières de
façon féroce plutôt qu'en extérieur
alors en extérieur il ya quelques
endroits
effectivement dans les rues piétonnes
dans les rues commerçantes encore
pendant les vacances dans les
embarcadères quand vous entendez un
bateau vous restez le surplace avec des
gens très proches qu'on a un moment là
effectivement il ya un petit risque mais
depuis la fête de la musique on sait
quand même que en extérieur même sans
respecter les mesures barrières le
risque de contamination est celle donc m
des masques comme j'ai entendu pour les
moteurs et pour les gens qui roulent en
scooter franchement c'est pas régional
jean-paul hamon vous parliez à l'instant
des lieux clos demain ce sont des
milliers d'élèves qui vont faire leur
retour sur le sur les bancs de l'école
des classes close
le corps enseignant est inquiet 1 avec
cc mais ces mesures barrières et ses
annonces du gouvernement à ce que vous
partagez elle les inquiétudes du corps
enseignant on partir du moment où les
enseignants sont sont basques et où les
élèves les élèves sont masquées il ya
quand même relativement peu de risques
je pense que les enfants ont maintenant
ont compris depuis le temps qu'on répète
qu'il faut se laver les mains qu'il faut
mettre un masque bon moi je pense même
sincèrement que à partir de 6 ans on
pourrait très bien demander aux enfants
de porter un masque
même si il y aura des forcément des
erreurs mais vous savez quand on est
enseignant on est on est capable de dire
aux enfants et d'expliquer pourquoi il
faut mettre
pourquoi il faut mettre un masque
pourquoi et post avait les mains et puis
quand les enfants iront voir l'enfant
par an ils savent très bien qu'il faut
pas faire de câlins pour apaiser et puis
vous savez maintenant les gens ont
changé les habitudes ils sont pas des
grands des grands cas là il touche le
coude
istres garde pour le sport et il se voit
et c'est sa principale
alors aujourd'hui la barre symbolique
des 900 milles test a été
dépasser le gouvernement espère franchir
la barre des d 1 million est-ce que
c'est assez doit-on d'autant faire plus
encore non le le bon le million test
c'est largement suffisant parce qu'il
faudrait surtout c'est que si obtenir
des résultats beaucoup plus rapidement
et puis identifier les cas contacts au
rapide pourrait identifier les cas
contactez rapidement ce qui est
important c'est que quelqu'un qui est
testé on de voir leurs résultats dans
les 12 heures ou au cutter dans les 24
heures pour pouvoir identifier les cas
contactez pouvoir tester les cas
contacts et d isoler si besoin
donc c'est ça qui est important
maintenant merci beaucoup jean paul
hamon d'avoir été avec nous ce matin sur
arte france rappelle que vous êtes
médecin généraliste et président
d'honneur de la fédération des médecins
de france